je m'excuse j'ai j'ai pas menti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est génial
il me fait signe à chaque fois donc
comme ta menti on va te faire une
interview mensonge d'accord j'arrive pas
à vous vouvoyer Philippe excusez-moi
dis-moi c'est mieux bon alors donc
l'interview mensonge il faut répondre
sans dire la vérité la vache
est-ce que vous pensez Philippe Gildas
qui a une bonne ambiance à Canal
oui
[Rires]
il est convaincant
est-ce que vous pensez Philippe Gildas
que votre émission actuelle est un
succès oui
est-ce que Jérôme Bonaldi vous étonne
tous les jours oui
escalin de greffe a toujours de
merveilleuses idées
Joker
est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu
dommage qu'on n'ait pas vu cette
émission avec Florence Belkacem et Guy
Bedos oui
est-ce que c'est vrai
est-ce que est-ce que vous c'est
difficile est-ce que vous c'est vrai que
l'émission que de Fogiel et Ruquier le
samedi matin qui s'appelle un an de plus
est-ce que c'est vrai que vous en ratez
pas une
à la question est mal formulée non
vous êtes content que la gaffe était lu
personnalité de l'année au set d'or
oui
est-ce que c'est vrai
je m'excuse j'ai pas menti
est-ce que vous est-ce que c'est vrai
qu'avec Maryse vous fréquentez les
boîtes échangistes oui
c'est là où il a échangé Maryse
est-ce que c'est vrai que j'avais un
sexe énorme oui
c'est vrai que vous fumez 15 pétards par
jour oui
[Rires]
que c'est pas bien de fumer parce que ça
empêche de bien travailler ensuite même
à la Jamaïque c'est comme ça qu'elle
sort indice tous les 5 ans en même temps
tous les trois
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu